hi everyone
welcome back to the regional session
we're delighted to bring you this
session
focused on how dna is used by law
enforcement
and crime labs to solve crime we are
very privileged today to have professor
adrian lineker to be our chair for this
session
at the end of all presentations there
will be an opportunity for us to answer
some of your questions
but in the meantime you can definitely
just submit all your questions in the q
a box below
as a reminder this session offers free
continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner
of the presentation window and follow
that process to obtain your credits
at that top right section you can also
find the complete bios of our speakers
there
so without further ado let me pass the
ball to professor adrian lineker who
will start sharing the session adrian
please
thank you beatrice uh welcome all
welcome all
now we actually have three excellent
speakers in the lead of their field
mass power sequencing and rapid dna now
their biographies are available
i'm not going to do anything like that i
don't want to eat into their times any
more than they need to e
um and as uh beatrice says we're gonna
leave all the questions till the end but
please start putting your questions i
will see them on my screen
so i'll get involved with them and we
can put those to the speakers right at
the end
the first speaker is a recorded talk
on their use of rapid dna in particular
fascinating work that they're doing in
field testing so
without further ado can we have talk
so in conjunction with rapid dna testing
we also try to target rapid samples
what i mean by this is samples that are
readily accessible and present in highly
decomposed remains
and easy to collect we also sought
sample types that would not only be easy
to collect and sample
but would also but would allow a minimal
sample preparation
so these factors led us to samples like
nail tissue biopsy
hair and small bones by choosing samples
such as these will negate the need for a
more invasive
labor intensive sample collection such
as for fema
followed by extensive preparation and
processing steps
having introduced some of the sample
types i'll now address
exactly what i mean about minimal
preparation really it addresses both the
collection and sample preparation
in terms of sample collection the
samples can be collected by simply
picking up or cutting
in terms of preparation prior to dna
processing
i refer to avoiding things such as
repeated washing steps and incubations
because these are the things that add
time to what might be defined as rapid
processing
therefore by using these sample types
our sample preparation can be
as simple as cutting off excess swab
shaft
cutting nail into smaller pieces rinsing
debris such as soil or decomposition
fluid off with water
wrapping biopsy tissue around a swab
cutting fta card containing biological
material
or directly adding bone shavings into
the chamber
the rapid hit id system uses a primary
cartridge which is where the sample is
added
one cartridge holds and tests one sample
taking approximately 90 minutes
note that the sample chamber itself is
long and narrow and that's it's
because it's designed for a swab where
the swab containing the actual
biological material is down bottom
so here 300 microliters of lysis buffer
is added and then removed from the
sample chamber
before proceeding for direct pcr
now as forensic scientists we're always
trying to see what we can get away with
usually on something that works
perfectly fine the way it was actually
designed to
but we know we have a long narrow
chamber
where we can insert our sample and where
our lysis buffer enters
a sample on the left is perhaps more of
an ideal sample amount of volume
conversely on the right we have 500
milligrams of bone powder which is
simply too much sample for
a few reasons we're able to still
include a swab in the chamber with the
sample on the left and that swab
actually assists in holding the sample
down
when the lysis buffer comes into the
chamber this can help with the
submersion of the sample
we recovered partial global fire express
profiles for most of our different
sample types however the format and
amounts of the different samples
varied while we did recover a partial
profile with bone shavings
this was only able to be achieved on one
sample
our nail and tissue biopsy samples seem
to work somewhat consistently
but while we would still seek to
determine the optimum amount of sample
we found that mostly at least one of
nail or tissue biopsy from the same
individual would yield a partial profile
testing these types of samples means
we're making them be compatible with the
sample cartridge
so for starters we could just find a way
to use a swab as the system
has been designed to do but we can just
incorporate the swab
so the best example here is the tissue
biopsy
we were wrapping the tissue around the
swab head which gives maximum surface
area exposure to the lysis buffer
making that interaction as efficient as
possible
another thing we saw was a sample moving
around in the sample chamber
so while the swab can hold or pin the
sample down
sample substrate can be moved due to the
injection of the lysis buffer
a fish's efficient lysis is achieved by
the interaction with the substrate so if
it's moving in the chamber that lysis
may not be sufficient
occasionally when pulling out the
cartridge at the end of a run we
actually saw nail clippings or similar
floating on top
the optimal amount of sample material
does need to be determined whether it's
on a swab or in the chamber
it is possible that less may be more we
only have that 300 microliters of lysis
buffer so it needs to interact optimally
with the sample substrate
obviously 300 microliters of lysis
buffer has no chance against 500
milligrams of bone powder
and and finally i just mentioned the
direct pcr action may mean we're more
susceptible to inhibitors with these
sample types
sample types like bone contain
inhibitors and we have other inhibitors
in the form of decomposition byproducts
or soil
we may need to balance this with a quick
cleanup
so in the case of the bone shavings that
appear that they absorb the lysosphere
ultimately leading to a failed analysis
and this is further complicated when too
much bone is
used in the case of dirty samples
causing inhibition or clogged
capillaries
a narrow notice will appear but it can
be as simple as running a blank in
between to make sure there are no issues
with carryover
in the event of a failed analysis it can
be difficult to distinguish between no
or low dna or inhibition and and this
these would would usually guide further
testing
um i guess finally i'd say that the
variability
of a dvi means that samples even of the
same type can be dramatically different
we saw that nails for example can be
clean covered in decomposition fluid or
attached to tissue
and often even missing by the time an
individual got to the temporary
monitoring
so now i'll pass on to ali to to
continue
thanks jeremy so i'm just going to
provide a few general comments and
observations for the
field deployment of rapid dna um
and and realistically it this exercise
has been of great benefit towards this
and i know there are other validation
um so there is other validation work
going on around the globe towards this
however in relation to this exercise
system validation
must be conducted to ensure there is
confidence in the outcomes and this
relates not to just technical in-lab
validation but very relevant on
operational deployed environment
the workflow development to integrate
sampling process at
earliest opportunity so that this is
related to the integration into the
field id
process and it's very important that
this is done well
to ensure you get early returns
connectivity connectivity could be
important
it is possible to have this back to base
scenario
especially where you might find results
uh interpretation
might be very complex and require a
scientific expert who may not be present
in the field
and that can be advantageous and clear
result representation
it's very important those results that
are provided and not so scientifically
focused
rather have the ability to provide that
matching information to a lay person
speed versus outcomes
so fast turnaround time may not equal a
unitable result or usable outcome
readjust and align quality standards
specifically for rapid dna including our
scientific result
expectation this is a question that i
would like to
pose and for people to have some thought
around
i think it's important to consider that
maybe deeper relevant validation for the
confidence in outcomes
and and that maybe scientists should
consider
concessions in their expectations from a
laboratory-based model
towards a more modified rapid dna
technical model and that is something to
to seriously think about if we think
about the rapid dna legislation in the
u.s
it won't allow our clothes to code us
due to there no being no
quantitation step um so you know
changing our expectations and without
compromise on
standards of result of course that is
that balance
it could help to address this and also
consider integration with smart software
potentially
for a faster and more robust
interpretation and that can take a lot
of
that um scientific hard work
into those complex results they can take
some of that away
so in general with the field deployment
um
a usable easy platform for quick setup
minimal intervention so the placement of
the unit
on scene is important and will maximize
its integration in the dvi
process and impact on the timing of
potentially either repatriation or
identification
of remains and that leads into sample
throughput per run is important
so whether that unit has one channel
that runs per time sorry per you know
90 minutes or you have a
series of individual single units which
can run
simultaneously or the one instrument as
i say that could have say
six to eight samples or more at any one
time
so thinking a little bit out of the box
it doesn't have to be that one unit
it could be several training training is
very important
um there is a non-coders rapid dna
considerations and best practices paper
um specifically being developed for law
enforcement it is us-based in relation
to the rapid dna
act however it's not a it's quite a good
paper it talks about that
importance of training
your non-scientific personnel the
environmental impact is challenging in a
dvi
and in this exercise it was very
challenging it was that four seasons in
one day we went from
extreme heat dust to
storms uh torrential rain
electrical storms and mud copious mud
so from the heat to the humidity
to the dry it is important that these
platforms and their consumables
can actually cope with that variation in
that environmental
um challenges so
adaptability is key and and i stick to
this there is no room
for princess platforms and consumables
they cannot
be requiring you know a temperate
climate to perform adequately
these systems need to be able to adapt
uh in
in order for us to maximize their um
integration
into the field and field deployment
especially for scenes like this
so in conclusion the rapid hit
id system demonstrated its utility for
assisting with the rapid
on-site identification and reassociation
of human remains at a mass fatality
incident
and in a remote environment by both dna
specialists
and police users a range of different
postmortem sample types can be applied
to the rapid hit
id system but further optimization
is recommended for highly decomposed and
skeletonized human remains
definitely having a rapid platform on
scene for faster development of dna
results is highly beneficial however
the simplicity of platform use does not
translate to simplicity of results for
scene work and that's something
to remember requires ruggedization for
true field deployment
platform and consumables the validation
of system technical limits and support
workflows is necessary
for confidence in outcomes when working
in fields and whether that be a lay
person interpreting
or a scientific staff member
reporting thank you
so in the interest of time we have
romani thara man
i really apologize if i'm not pronounced
your name correctly
right now we're talking about mass
parallel sequencing next
on how that would happen in um
looking at geographical and ancestry
markers
the biography of amber dr ramani is
online
anyway so without further ado please
take the floor
okay good afternoon and thank you for
joining in on this virtual conference
my name is remini and i have been a
forensic scientist with the dna
profiling laboratory
at health sciences authority in
singapore for eight years
today i will be talking on the topic
doing more with less
but first a disclaimer
before i start on today's topic for
sharing i would like to give a short
introduction
to who we are and what we do
we are the sole national accredited
forensic dna laboratory in singapore
we have been accredited with asplat lab
since 1996
and recently transitioned over to a b
as part of the human identification
services we provide to law enforcement
our standard dna profiling workflow
involves
semi-automated extraction using promega
iq
chemistry on the maxwell fsc
quantitation using quantifier duo on the
quan studio 7
pcr using global filer on the proflex
and capillary electrophoresis on the 24
cap 3500
xl we then issue our final reports which
are then tendered in court
here our selection of our publications
and procedures we have developed or
validated for use in case work
for investigative purposes we used
emerging technologies
which have the potential but we feel are
not yet ready for use in court
we have both massively parallel
sequencing platforms in place
and use them for prediction of
biogeographic ancestry
external externally visible phenotypes
and whole genome mitochondrial dna
sequencing
we use the kaijen pyromark for
pyrosequencing
to predict age by looking at the
proportion of methylation at three
predictors
elov l2 trim 59 and klf14
we have also validated the use of the
rapid hit system for urgent cases back
in 2015
in forensic casework the samples that we
deal with
are mostly compromised with questionable
quality
and typically very limited quantities
the forensic community is continuously
working to address these limitations
in line with this we are currently
evaluating the new promega
bone dna kit it has shown promising
results for use with difficult body
remain samples
such as those seen in dvi situations
however this will not be the focus of
today's sharing
the basis of doing more with less
relates to being able to get more value
more data more savings in terms of cost
and or time with less input
today i will be sharing with you two
methods which we have developed
to be able to do more with less
i will start off with microflow direct
amplification first
the copen microflow direct swab is one
which was specific
specially designed for direct sampling
and amplification
what is special about this micro swab is
its small nylon fiber tip which has been
pre-treated
to allow for institute lysis
it also has a breakage point to allow
the tip to be snapped off directly
into a pcr tube or plate for direct
pcr amplification
we use the microflow swab by
lightly moistening the tip with
deionized water
applying the swab perpendicularly to the
stain in question
giving the swab a few twists and then
returning the swab to its holder
subsequently the swab head is snapped
off into a pcr tube containing the
global filer master mix
and processed as per our standard
workflow
given the small size of the nylon fiber
tip you can see
how little sample is consumed thus
leaving sufficient sample for subsequent
testing
the benefits that this method of
sampling and direct amplification has
offered are multi-fold
as mentioned there is minimal sample
consumption
with sufficient sample left for
subsequent testing
it is an easy to do procedure with
almost
no additional training no additional
equipment
and easily integrated in our existing
workflow
because we are skipping the extraction
and quantitation steps
we are able to turn around results in
three hours
which is especially useful for urgent
cases
furthermore unlike rapid dna systems
which use
either one three five or seven sample
cartridges
and any additional samples would be
would mean
additional 90 minutes or under two hour
runs
again depending on which rapid dna
system you're talking about
the use of microflow direct
amplification allows
us to process up to 20 samples
and controls in the 24 cap ce system to
be run
in the same three hours
this is also cheaper than standard
processing by 14
and up to 20 times cheaper per sample
compared to rapid dna systems
some laboratories would have concerns
with direct amplification
due to requirements for consensus-based
reporting of mixed dna profiles
or with capillary electrophoresis
artifacts due to over-amplification
we too had these issues and sought to
see how we could improve on this method
to address these concerns we realized we
needed to generate a lysate
so instead of snapping the microflow
head into a tube containing our master
mix
it went into some low te buffer and a
short incubation later
to allow the lifestyle contents to enter
the buffer
this provided us with sufficient volume
for multiple amplifications using
globophylum
and the option of varying the amount of
lysate used for amplification
we evaluated this modification with
blood stained on a wide variety of
substrates
and reported on the performance of this
well i'm sorry about that we seem to
have frozen technology
um i'm sure we can catch back to um dr
amani in due course
but rather than just staring at a frozen
screen
we've cut into luke the next talker
who seems to be ready to take on the
slack
at very short notice is that okay with
you luke
yep yes i'm ready
well take the floor
all right good afternoon everybody um
today i'm
presenting on a research project that i
completed recently
assessing massively parallel sequencing
as an investigative
investigative tool so the intent of the
research
uh was to collaborate with queensland
police service with the detectives
and they're our end users so we wanted
to collaborate with them to assess
the mps we assess both biogeographic
ancestry
and hair and eye color externally
visible characteristics
and the assessment we assessed in terms
of operational effectiveness so we
wanted to
determine how could that mps
assist a real investigation in
queensland
my intention was if we had positive
findings to use the findings of this
research
as a justification uh in a in a business
case for instrument purchase
and also to use this model of assessing
operational effectiveness with the end
users as a model for assessing
future panels
so what did we actually do the
extraction and dna quantification we
performed in queensland in
our forensic labs there and we traveled
to melbourne to the thermo fisher
labs to do the mps analysis
we used the precision id ancestry
panel the commercial panel and the dna
phenotyping
a community panel and we process that on
the
ion chef and the s5 xl
so what methodology did we use we
selected four
real queensland cases and i think it's
uh it's important
to emphasize this was deliberate because
we wanted to use
real queensland cases so that our
assessment was as close as possible
to a real life situation
and a real investigation we conducted
mps analysis
only of the offender reference samples
we didn't process any crime scene
samples because we didn't want to
unnecessarily consume those
we used those results and
interpreted the nps results to prepare
intelligence reports which were
presented to the detectives
we collected uh mug shot photographs of
each of the offenders
uh and all of the pois from the cases
and their physical descriptions
and we had for some of the uh some of
the pois we have
multiple mug shots that have been
collected
over over years and it was interesting
to note that some of the physical
descriptions weren't consistent with
their
with their mugshots and then we
conducted workshops in person with the
detectives
so as i said we selected real cr
queensland criminal cases
and we used a number of criteria to
select these cases
uh we wanted large numbers of persons of
interest because this is one of the
applications of mps
to prioritize those large lists of
pois we wanted pois with a range of
appearances and ancestries and
this is what we could use to actually
prioritize that list the differences in
their appearance and ancestries
we obviously needed a good quality
photograph for each of the pois
and we wanted to keep things as real as
possible we wanted to have offended dna
located at the crime scene
and obviously we needed that reference
sample of the offender
to actually process so just a a
i guess a broad overview of the cases
that we used
these are the four cases that we
analyzed the first was
an eight linked sexual offenses and home
invasions but
these happened over a number of years
and for the
for the uh i guess the entire
investigation the the offender was not
uh was an unknown offender and there was
a very large number
of pos investigated for that
investigation
the second was ten linked sexual
offenses over a short a period of time
but still an unknown offender
the third was a murder of a female
victim now this only had one poi which
was the offender
but we included this case because the
offender was actually identified
using cctv so we wanted to see whether
the detectives could
use the mps intelligence to compare that
to the cctv imagery
and the fourth and final one was the
murder of a female victim
there were eight pois and they were from
a range of ancestries
so the actual workshops what did we do
we had 28 police detectives who
participated
and the the way that they flowed we we
gave a case scenario so we gave the
background of the offense
the mo and if there was multiple
offenses we we gave we gave that for
each offence
we gave the investigation history so we
walked the detectives through
what the actual process that had been
conducted for the investigation for each
of the cases
we gave the dna results so the actual
dna results that were available
and then we inserted the mps results in
the form of the of an intelligence
report i've got one of those i can show
you
then we gave the detectives
all of the mugshots so so all of the
pois
and the offenders obviously we didn't
identify who the offender was
and we asked them to use the
intelligence reports to make
include exclude or unsure assessments
on each of the pois so could those pois
be included or excluded using the
intelligence report
and we also collected a range of other
metrics which i'll describe
so this is an example of the
intelligence reports that we
that we generated so at the top we had
some just some case details sample
details
and then in the results we made two
types of statements
so you can see at the bottom of the the
first page of this intelligence report
we made
a series of likely statements so for
example for hot eye color
we said that the donor is likely to have
brown eyes
on the second page for each of the
ancestry hair color eye color
we also made a series of not likely
statements so
again for eye color we said that the
donor is not likely to have
blue or intermediate eyes and these are
the statements that
the detectives use to assess the uh
the photographs of each of the pois and
you'll know that we didn't give them the
raw data the raw mps analysis data
so the metrics that we collected that we
use to assess the operational
effectiveness
uh firstly confidence so
what was the accuracy how did the
detectives rate the accuracy
and the robustness of that intelligence
and what was their willingness to use
the intelligence in an investigation
we asked them to rate their value so did
they believe that the mps intelligence
had a positive
or negative impact on the investigation
would it direct it in a in an
informative direction or would it
mislead the director of the
investigation
we assessed their population group
awareness so for the ancestry root
populations
what we did was for the likely
statements
we asked them to use a we gave them a
map of the world and some
and some coloring in pencils and we
asked them to circle the areas
that they felt that were represented by
the likely
uh uh statements for the for ancestry
so if we said europe we asked them to
color in if it was likely to have
european ancestry we asked them to
colour in those areas on the map
we looked at whether the offender was
included or excluded obviously that's a
key metric
um and then we looked at the percentage
of pois
that were excluded
so the results uh confidence
two-thirds of the of the detectives and
this is a summary of
for each of the cases um two-thirds
assessed their confidence is greater
than fifty percent
and this was again a measure of how they
felt how accurate and robust they
thought the intelligence was
and what was their willingness to use it
so you can
you can see there there was a level of
confidence there that it could be used
and i i guess i should say that
all of these detectives none of them had
previous experience with mps
so i would be concerned if they had a
very high level of confidence in
in uh mps because of its
because it's intelligence by its nature
uh value so 90 of respondents accept it
assess it as having positive value which
means and we gave these descriptors on
the response sheet
so they knew what they were they knew
what they were saying when they assessed
the value
they they felt that the mps provided
avenues for investigation and had the
potential to indicate a suspect pool
so that was a positive that they felt
that it had a positive value
population group awareness um
so this is where we assessed their
knowledge their their familiarity with
the root populations
provided in the in the ancestry results
what we found broadly was they had a
generally good idea
of of the root populations and you can
see we assessed whether they had
uh whether they fully indicated the
correct area
whether there was partial so they didn't
include any incorrect areas but partial
with no errors
partial with errors and then fully
incorrect we didn't get any fully
incorrect
but we saw some partial no errors so
for example if they were looking at the
european area they would exclude areas
they might only include parts of eastern
europe
where we found the detectives
had less familiarity was with oceania
and with the asian root populations and
i think that this
these results and in speaking to the
detectives in the workshop
these are the results that really
reinforce the need
for that trained forensic biologist to
provide this
the mps intelligence to the detectives
who have limited familiarity with it
and to coach them through the process of
how it can be used
offender include exclude so we found
that there was across the four cases
there was only one instance uh where one
of the detectives excluded the offender
the exclusion was based on ancestry
alone
and when we looked into that
decision-making process we found that
that detective
for case four there was a group of four
pois who had the same ancestry and the
same phenotypes the same externally
visible characteristics
and the detective used the intelligence
to include two of those persons and
exclude two
so it was a bit hard to understand the
decision-making process that was used
and that's why i say if that's an
example
where that decision would be avoidable
uh with
uh the forensic scientist assisting
the pi exclusion rates so uh overall
averaged across the cases we had about a
30
exclusion rate so and i think that this
um
sorry i should say that that assessment
was based on the overall assessment that
we asked them to make so for each
for each poi we asked the detectives to
make individual assessments
of whether they could include or exclude
based on hair
eye and ancestry and then we asked them
to make a fourth assessment
overall taking into account each of
those elements
what would they what would their final
decision be so they may include
on here and i exclude on ancestry but
their
overall assessment may be to include
so that poi exclusion rate we saw about
a 30
exclusion rate and that really
reinforced
the utility of the mps to
prioritize large lists of pois so
the start of an investigation where
there's
an unknown offender big list of pois
then this could be
one of the tools that the detectives
could use to
start prioritizing that poi list
so the findings i guess in summary the
confidence and value assessments
really demonstrated that the detectives
felt that the mps intelligence had
utility and they were willing to use it
again i stressed that they didn't have
prior experience with it so the fact
that they
they saw value in it with limited
exposure i thought was very promising
there was only one offender exclusion
and i said this was a critical metric
whether the offender was excluded
because obviously if we exclude the
offender then that's
very misleading for the investigation
and that was that exclusion was
non-intuitive so
that really reinforced the need for the
trained forensic biologist to deliver
uh interpreted nps results to the to the
detectives and not
not just provide the raw results to them
the the 30 poi exclusion rate really
demonstrated the effectiveness for
cases with a large suspect pool or
possibly if mass screenings are proposed
it really demonstrates that the
potential to
prioritize those suspect lists to cut
down on the investigative hours and to
accelerate an investigation
and as i've said a couple of times it
all of the results
highlighted that need for the forensic
biologist to interpret and deliver that
intelligence to the detectives
so the outcome um we assessed the mps
uh as being operationally effective and
we use those findings
in a in a successful business case and
we were lucky enough to be able to
purchase our own nps instruments which
you can see pictured there
and we're about to excuse me we're about
to commence the validation of those now
uh just some disclaimers
which you can consume in your own time
and i think we're holding questions to
the end
all right thank you very much
so can you pick off where you went or
where we were before thank you very much
okay um sorry about that folks um
technical difficulties with blue screen
errors
so um just to recap so before i got cut
off
i was talking about how we also had
issues with consensus based reporting
and over amplification artifacts on ce
so to address these concerns we realized
we needed to generate a lysate
so instead of snapping off the microflow
head into a tube containing a master mix
it went into some low te buffer and
a short incubation to allow the light
cell contents to enter the buffer
this provided us with sufficient volume
for multiple amplifications using global
filer
and the option of varying the amount of
lysate used
for amplification we evaluated this
modification with blood stained
on a wide variety of substrates and
reported
on the performance of this compared to
our standard sample processing
of cotton swabs of the bloodstains on
the different exhibit types
these box plots show the range in median
peak
heights in the dna profiles obtained
from blood on the different substrates
straight away we can see that there was
much vital variation
in rfu observed with modified micro floc
procedure
because of the natural variation in
template used for amplification
because no quantitation was performed
compared to the standard method
overall we obtained complete dna
profiles
for the modified microflow across all
the substrates
with well balanced system peaks and the
majority of peaks above
our stochastic threshold
in the last two substrates we observed
that the modified microflow workflow
was able to generate complete dna
profiles where our standard workflow
failed to produce any reportable peaks
here we see an excerpt from the
respective electroferograms
in the standard processing there was no
inhibition detected during quantitation
the internal positive control ct values
were no different
from other non-inhibited samples
we believe that the humic acid in the
soil may have competitively sequestered
the release dna during extraction
and hence there was no dna eluted
on the left are photos showing what
blood
on the soil stain fabric and rock look
like
and so in addition to the benefits
highlighted earlier
and with a slight increase in processing
time
we have also addressed the concerns of
ce artifacts due to over
amplification and gain the ability
to do replicate amplifications to allow
consensus reporting of dna profiles
by adopting this modified microflow
direct amplification method
we have been able to do more with less
moving on i will next be sharing about
ancestry prediction
using ystr dna profiles
we have been doing predictions for
biogeographic ancestry
using ancestry informative markers
genotypes on the illumina
massively parallel sequencing platform
using
custom reference populations for the
predominant chinese
malay and indian populations in
singapore
and using the online sniper tool
this has allowed us to predict ancestry
with an accuracy of about 90 percent
and the ability to detect admixture
between these ancestry groups when
present
at a one is to one up to a trees to one
ratio
however this capability required
additional sample consumption
significant cost and a four to five day
wait for the mps results
we know that why haplogroups are
biogeographically linked
as you can see by the multiple colors
associated with the different regions of
the world
in our laboratories we have already been
performing ystr dna profiling for a
number of years
and for increasingly more case types
analysis of ystr profiles generated in
our laboratory
over the past few years showed that we
had about
66 000 unique haplotypes
from about 78 000 wifiler plus dna
profiles
the frequency distribution of these
haplotypes show
that the majority nearly three-quarters
are seen only once
otherwise known as singletons
we use shannon's entropy as a measure of
information content between our
populations
in the y tested white loci this is
influenced by the proportion of alleles
at each locus if you look at the formula
we observe that the y str loci
are quite rich in information contents
from the bar plots dys385
and dyf387s1
both of which are multi-copy markers and
so have the most number of alleles among
the tested loci
also have the highest information
content
we looked at linkage disequilibrium
across the ystr low side
and observed that despite inclusion of
rapidly mutating ystr markers
the entire set of ystr loci were all
very strongly linked
the high degree of shared information
that we saw in the previous slide
combined with the strong non-recombining
properties of the loci
and the generally reported low
occurrence of mutation
at between 10 to the minus 4 and 10 to
the minus 2 per generation
meant that there was preservation of
ethnicity information in the ystr
profiles
thus allowing them to be used for
ancestry inference
we decided to use machine learning
algorithms to model the differences
in our local chinese malay and indian
populations
we didn't know how the ystr would behave
and didn't know which ones would work
the best
and so we tried to cover most classes of
machine learning algorithms
such as support vector classification
tree based modeling with different
boosting techniques
neural networks and k-nearest neighbors
we further supplemented these algorithms
with two additional classifying
algorithms
which took input from the latter four
models and gave
a prediction either based on the
majority if you look at the voting
classifier
or based on neural network modeling if
you look at the stacking classifier
while each of these machine learning
algorithms had slightly different
accuracies
they were generally able to lead to the
same predictions
five different algorithms leading to the
same answer
reinforced that the predictions were
accurate at around 90 percent accuracy
and this was reiterated by the two
classifier algorithms
so effectively because we had already
been performing ystr dna profiling on
increasingly more case types
we were also able to do ancestry
prediction using machine learning
without any additional sample
consumption
additional costs or the typical four to
five day wait for mps results
and so we have succeeded in doing more
with less
to continuously improve on our
capabilities following this team
we hope to expand the use of the
modified microflow technique to include
siemens stains
and as well as to expand the use of the
machine learning algorithms for ancestry
prediction in other
asian populations
with that i come to the end of my
presentation i would like to acknowledge
hsa
the organization which i work for for
giving us the backing
and opportunity to continue to be the
national forensic dna laboratory
thermal fisher for giving us the chance
to share with all of you today
and everyone from our laboratories were
contributed to the research and
developments mentioned so far
do you have any questions for me
thank you very much excellent talk
we actually have a couple of questions
for
for the panelists um which i've got
online at the moment
please anyone else wanting to put
questions in do so
now we do actually have a question about
what i think may have been answered
halfway through the talk about the rapid
dna
what type of samples were collected at
the at the pm
um in jeremy do you answer that because
i talked about
the nails and bone samples is there
anything else like
hair and other types of material which
you may have talked about
yes i mean we we specifically focused on
our nails either fingernails or toenails
depending on the availability um as well
as the hair
we looked at the biopsy tissue such as
tissue
and then yeah that a couple of different
bones specifically femur
and foot bones
there was a follow-up question which i
can sort of summarize which is
again jeremy to you you might want to
take this one as well
is what were the problems of trying to
say pulverize
bone in field was that feasible
um there was challenges and and
basically the situation was we were
trying a range of different things but
we didn't necessarily find anything that
that worked the best so that is like
that we're continuing to try to develop
oh we only had a couple of questions but
i'll just raise one because we've got a
few seconds
um and maybe luke or dr romani might
take this
if we've got a lot of uh or any jodie
and ali actually
you're talking a lot about intelligence
now what would be the hurdles of
transitioning this from
intelligence because a lot of areas of
forensic science started off in
intelligence and then somehow ended up
in court
um so what would be any of the issues if
you wanted to transition this into real
casework
now let's try luke first
um can you hear me luke
all right i think i was muted you got me
now
you can hear me i think yep i think look
i think the big difference
uh is uh that the str
analysis has has some really good
statistical analysis
uh that can be used to provide
likelihood ratios and
and can be used in court to explain the
evidence
at the moment the mps just doesn't have
that there's
the i guess the the extent of it at the
moment are
like i had in those intelligence reports
those likely and not likely statements
so i think that that's a
that's a big limitation in its utility
in a court setting at the moment
what about yourself dr amani is there an
issue in singapore
well the biggest issue here is
acceptance by the courts
so um
well it's not really a problem it has
not been approached yet
well i mean even before acceptance by
the courts we first have to look at
validation
while validation while some laboratories
have started doing validation
guidelines are not confirmed they're not
ratified yet
next experiment you need to look at
testing off a large number of samples
to demonstrate robustness and
reproducibility
this is still in process right now and
moving forward so this
being able to do this large number of
samples will help
us demonstrate to others as the
community
as well as the courts the robustness and
the reproducibility
of the system and ultimately in the end
education to the court officials to
understand what
we are doing and what the results mean
and together with these education we
also need to talk about what the
limitations in the technology are
all this needs to come together before
we as a community
are ready to be able to transition this
from purely investigative work over to
casework
well i think direct pcr is something i
know a little bit about myself and
uh the issues are often about
reproducibility
i think we're going to wrap that up very
soon so unless anyone else got anything
particular to
to bring into the conversation
uh i was told to try and make sure we
finished around about three o'clock
and uh well three o'clock my time i
think it's three o'clock
3 30 somewhere else's time and goodness
knows what time it is elsewhere
so can i hold a hand back to um beatrice
yes um
thank you thank you very much for all
the speakers and
and agent for um being the chair of this
session
um we have a short video for you to play
um
christy if we can play peter's video
right now
hello this is peter waterman i'm the
global commercial leader for the thermo
fisher
scientific hid team it's been wonderful
to have been involved in the very first
fully virtual heads meeting this year
i've heard a lot about these meetings
over the years and to have now
experienced and seen the presentations
the posters the panel discussions and
the trade shows has reinforced to me the
true value of building interactions
and a sense of community and partnership
in hid across the world the theme of
this year's meeting is actually
partnership
in criminal justice this resonates
strongly
especially during these challenging
times when interaction
communication and support of each other
is so important
it has been an eye-opener to me how the
hid community can overcome these
challenges
and create a truly wonderful virtual
event
thank you to all of you the over two
thousand registered
and attendees who truly made this a
memorable occasion i'd like to thank in
particular session presenters
the panelists the moderators the poster
presenters you delivered significant
scientific value
one that actually parallels an in-person
event in many ways
i'd also like to thank the thermo fisher
scientific team
who've worked to bring this event
together thank you for the standard that
you have set
it is a standard that we hope to meet
and exceed in future meetings
back to the attendees i'd like to ask
you for a favor
your input your feedback is so important
to us to
continue to make this event useful
and also valuable to all of you
your suggestions your ideas your
feedback are incredibly important to us
please send those to us
we hope next year fingers crossed we
might be able to meet in person
but in the meantime we wish you all of
the safety
all of the best health to you your
families and your colleagues
and we look forward to talking to you
and meeting you again very soon
thank you
thank thank you peter let me echo his
thanks to all of you who have
joined us for this day um it's been
lovely having
all of you around in this virtual
environment i i do hope we'll bump into
each other into corridors again
but right now the 24 hours of hits
virtual 2020
is drawing to a close i do hope it was
as memorable for you as it was for me
um don't worry about missing any
presentations these presentations
from our session and the sessions
earlier are all available
on demand viewing up until june 2021
so please be sure to stop by again and
have a look at the rest of the
sessions thank you once again for your
participation
we are now going to open the technical
ask the expert chat
and that's in the um ask the expert chat
hall
that's only gonna be open for two hours
so don't miss it
at the same time the applications and
exhibition booth
and posters halls are still open so
please be sure to stop by
so thank you once again for your
participation here
see you at hits 2021 signing off